on the day they were dead
look at you beard
[Music]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
i
is
[Music]
um
uh
you're in a good place
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
it is
is
he was chairman within
they recognized
is
a lot
[Music]
it's
is
but it's like it's hard
the joint session will come to order
okay then we do these okay
the joint session will come to order
the chair appoints
as members of the committee on the part
of the house
to escort the president of the united
states
into the chambers
the gentleman from maryland mr hoyer
the gentleman from south carolina mr
clyburn
the gentleman from massachusetts the
gentlewoman from massachusetts ms clark
the gentleman from new york mr jefferies
the gentleman from new york mr sean
patrick maloney
the gentleman woman from ohio miss
captor
the gentlewoman from delaware miss bont
rochester
the gentleman from california mr
mccarthy
the gentleman from louisiana mr scalise
the gentlewoman from new york ms
stefanik the gentleman from louisiana mr
mike johnson the gentleman from alabama
mr palmer
the gentleman from oklahoma mr cole
the gentlewoman from indiana miss sparts
the president of the senate at the
direction of that body
appoints the following senators as
members of the committee on the part of
the senate to escort the president of
the united states into the house chamber
the senator from new york mr schumer
the senator from vermont mr leahy
the senator from illinois mr durbin
the senator from michigan miss snap now
the senator from minnesota ms klobuchar
the senator from wisconsin ms baldwin
the senator from kentucky mr mcconnell
the senator from south dakota mr thune
the senator from wyoming mr barrasso
the senator from iowa miss ernst
the senator from missouri mr blunt
and the senator from iowa mr grassley
the members of the escort committee will
exit the chamber through the lobby doors
now we wait
you guys
madam speaker the dean of the diplomatic
corps
[Applause]
cadmium
yes
remind me
[Music]
is
okay
madam speaker the chief justice and
associate justices of the supreme
thank
court
[Applause]
uh
next up is
nice
right
[Applause]
yes
madam speaker the president's cabinet
[Applause]
with
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i heard you need to talk to me
should i call you tomorrow
police
yes
[Music]
you know
some guys
[Laughter]
what do we do
um
died
uh
shoes
oh there he is
congratulations
[Music]
a tight schedule
[Laughter]
i'm very excited
um
[Applause]
right
madam speaker
the president of the united states
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
easily
[Applause]
right down here
[Applause]
members of congress
i have the high privilege and distinct
honor of presenting to you the president
of the united states
thank you thank you thank you
thank you all very much
thank you general
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you all very very much
thank you
please
thank you so much
[Applause]
madam speaker madam vice president our
first lady and second gentleman
members of congress in the cabinet
justice of the supreme court
my fellow americans
last year covet 19 kept us apart this
year we're finally together again
tonight
tonight we meet
as democrats republicans independents
but most importantly as americans
with the duty to one another
to america
to the american people to the
constitution
and an unwavering resolve
that freedom will always triumph over
tyranny
thank you
six days ago
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend to his
menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated
he thought he could roll into ukraine
and the world would roll over
instead
he met with a mall a wall of strength he
never anticipated or imagined he met the
ukrainian people
from president
zlinski
to every ukrainian their fearlessness
their courage and determination
literally inspires the world
groups of citizens
blocking tanks with their bodies
everyone from students to retirees to
teachers turned soldiers defending their
homeland
and in this struggle president zielinski
said in his speech to the european
parliament
light will win over darkness
ukrainian ambassador to the united
states is here tonight sitting with the
first lady
let each of us if you're able to stand
stand and send an unmistakable signal to
the world
thank you
thank you thank you thank you
the greatest challenge is resolved
[Applause]
yes
we the united states of america stand
with the ukrainian people
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson
when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving
and the costs the threats to the america
and america to the world
keeps rising
that's why the nato alliance was created
to secure peace and stability in europe
after world war ii
the united states is a member along with
29 other nations
it matters
american diplomacy matters
american resolve matters
putin's latest attack on ukraine
was premeditated
and totally unprovoked
he rejected repeated repeated efforts at
diplomacy
he thought the west and nato wouldn't
respond
he thought he could divide us at home in
this chamber in this nation
he thought he could divide us in europe
as well but putin was wrong
we are ready we are united and that's
what we did we stayed united we prepared
extensively and carefully we spent
months building coalitions of other
freedom-loving nations in europe and the
americas to america to the asian and
african continents
to confront putin
like many of you i spent countless hours
unifying your european allies
we shared with the world in advance what
we knew putin was planning and precisely
how we would try to falsify
and justify his aggression
we countered russia's lies with the
truth
and now now that he's acted
the three free world is holding him
accountable
along with 27 members of the european
union including france germany italy as
well as countries like the united
kingdom canada japan korea australia new
zealand and many others even switzerland
are inflicting pain on russia
and supporting the people of ukraine
putin is now isolated from the world
more than he has ever been
together
together
together along with our allies we are
right now enforcing powerful economic
sanctions
we're cutting off russia's largest banks
in the international financial system
preventing russia's central bank from
defending the russell
ruble making putin's 630 billion dollar
war fund worthless
we're choking russia's access
we're choking russia's access to
technology that will sap its economic
strength and weaken its military for
years to come
tonight
i say to the russian oligarchs and the
corrupt leaders who built billions of
dollars off this violent regime no more
the united states
i mean it
the united states
department of justice is assembling a
dedicated task force to go after the
crimes of the russian oligarchs
we're joining with european allies to
find and seize their yachts their luxury
apartments their private jets
we're coming for you ill-begotten gains
and tonight i'm announcing that we will
join our allies in closing off american
airspace to all russian flights further
isolating russia and adding additional
squeeze on their economy
he has no idea what's coming
the ruble has already lost 30 of his
value
the russian stock market has lost 40
percent of its value
and trading remains suspended
the russian economy is reeling
and putin alone is the one to blame
together with our allies we're providing
support to the ukrainians in their fight
for freedom
military assistance
economic assistance humanitarian
assistance we're giving more than a
billion dollars of direct assistance
ukraine and will continue to aid
ukrainian people as they defend their
country and help ease their suffering
but let me be clear
our forces are not
engaged and will not engage in the
conflict with russian forces in ukraine
our forces are not going to europe to
fight ukraine but to defend our nato
allies in the event that putin decides
to keep moving west
for that purpose we have mobilized
american ground forces air squadrons
ship deployments to protect nato
countries including poland romania
latvia lithuania and estonia and as i've
made crystal clear
the united states and our allies will
defend every inch of territory that is
nato territory for the full force of our
collective power every single inch
and we're clear-eyed
the ukrainians are fighting back with
pure courage
but the next few days weeks and months
will be hard on them
putin has unleashed violence and chaos
but while he may make gains on the
battlefield he'll pay a continuing high
price over the long run
and a pound of ukrainian people proud
proud people pound for pound ready to
fight with every inch of energy they
have
they've known 30 years of independence
have repeatedly shown that they will not
tolerate anyone who tries to take their
country backwards
to all americans
i'll be honest with you as i always
promised i would be
a russian dictator of fame
invading the foreign country has cost
around the world
and i'm taking robust action to make
sure the pain of our sanctions is
targeted at russian economy
and that we use every tool at our
disposal to protect american businesses
and consumers
tonight
i can announce the united states has
worked with 30 other countries to
release 60 million barrels of oil from
reserves around the world
america
will lead that effort
we didn't see 30 million bars of our own
strategic petroleum reserve
and we stand ready to do more if
necessary united with our allies
these steps will help blunt gas prices
here at home
but i know news about what's happening
can seem alarming to all americans
but i want you to know
we're going to be okay
we're going to be okay
when the history of this era is written
putin's war in ukraine will have left
russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
well
while it shouldn't
while it shouldn't have taken
well it shouldn't have taken something
so terrible for people around the world
to see what's at stake
now everyone sees it clearly
we see the unity among leaders of
nations a more unified europe a more
unified west
we see unity among the people who are
gathering in cities
and large crowds around the world even
in russia to demonstrate their support
for the people of ukraine
and the battle between democracy and
autocracies
democracies are rising to the moment
and the world is clearly choosing the
side of peace and security
this is the real test
and it's going to take time
so let's continue to draw inspiration
from the iron will of the ukrainian
people
to our fellow ukrainian americans
who forge the deep bond that connects
our two nations
we stand with you we stand with you
putin may circle keeve with tanks but
it'll never gain the hearts and souls of
the iranian people
he'll never he'll never extinguish their
love of freedom
and he will never never weaken the
resolve of the free world
[Applause]
we meet tonight
in an america that has lived through
two of the hardest years this nation has
ever faced
the pandemic has been punishing
and so many families are living paycheck
to paycheck struggling to keep up with
the rising cost of food gas housing and
so much more
i understand like many of you did
my dad had to leave his home in scranton
pennsylvania to find work
so like many of you i grew up in a
family when the price of food went up it
was felt throughout the family it had an
impact
that's one of the first things i did as
president was fight to pass the american
rescue plan
because people were hurting
we needed to act and we did
few pieces of legislation have done more
at a critical moment in our history to
lift us out of a crisis
it fueled our efforts to vaccinate the
nation and combat coven-19
delivered immediate economic relief to
tens of millions of americans
it helped put food on the table remember
those long lines of cars waiting for
hours just to get a box of food put in
their trunk
it cut the cost of health care insurance
and as my dad used to say it gave the
people just a little bit of breathing
room
unlike the two trillion dollar tax cut
passed in the previous administration
that benefited the top one percent of
americans the american rescue plan
[Music]
the american rescue plan
helped working people and left no one
behind
folks
and it worked
it worked
it worked you created jobs lots of jobs
in fact our economy created over
6.5 million new jobs just last year
more jobs
in one year
than ever before in the history of the
united states of america
the economy grew at a rate of 5.7 last
year the strongest growth rate in 40
years
and the first step in bringing
fundamental change to our economy that
hasn't worked for working people in this
nation for too long
for the past 40 years
we were told the tax break for those of
the top and benefits would trickle down
and everyone would would benefit but
that trickle-down theory led to a weaker
economic growth
lower wages bigger deficits and a
widening gap between the top
and everyone else in in nearly a century
look
vice president harris and i ran for
office and i realized we had fundamental
disagreements on this
but ran for office of the new economic
vision for america invest in america
educate americans grow the workforce
build the economy from the bottom up in
the middle out not from the top down
because we know
because we know
because we know when the middle class
grows
when the middle class grows the poor of
a way up and the wealthy do very well
america used to have the best roads
bridges and airports on earth
and now
our infrastructure is ranked 13th in the
world
won't be able to compete for the jobs of
the 21st century if we don't fix it
that's why it was so important to pass
the bipartisan infrastructure law and i
thank my republican friends
to join
to invest
and rebuild america
the single biggest investment
in history
it was a bipartisan effort and i want to
thank the members of both parties who
work to make it happen we're done
talking about infrastructure weeks we're
now talking about an infrastructure
decade
and look
it's going
to
it's going to transform america
to put us on a path to win the economic
competition of 21st century that we face
with the rest of the world particularly
china
i told xi jinping it's never been a good
bet to bet against the american people
we'll create good jobs for millions of
americans modernizing roads airports
ports waterways all across america
and will do it
to withstand the devastating impacts of
climate change and promote environmental
justice
we'll build a national network of 500
000 electric vehicle charging stations
begin to replace the poisonous lead
pipes so every child every american has
clean water to drink at home and at
school
we're going to provide
provide affordable
high-speed internet for every american
rural suburban urban and tribal
communities
4 000 projects have already been
announced many of you have announced
them in your districts
and tonight i'm announcing that this
year
we will start fixing over 65 000 miles
of highway and 1
500 bridges in disrepair
and folks
when we use
taxpayers dollars to rebuild america
we're going to do it by buying america
buy american products
support american jobs
the federal government
spends about 600 billion a year to keep
this country safe and secure
there's been a law on the books for
almost a century to make sure taxpayers
dollars support american jobs and
businesses
every administration democrat and
republican says they'll do it
but we're actually we're actually doing
it
we'll buy america to make sure every
everything from the deck of an aircraft
carrier to the steel on highway guard
rails is made in america from beginning
to end all of it all of it
but folks
to compete for the jobs
of the future we also need a loving
playing field
with china
and other competitors
that's why it's so important to pass the
bipartisan innovation act sitting in
congress that will make record
investments in emerging technologies in
american manufacturing
we used to invest almost 2 percent of
our gdp in research and development
we don't now
can't
china is
let me give you one example why it's so
important to pass
if you travel 20 miles east of columbus
ohio you'll find a thousand empty acres
of land
it won't look like much
but if you stop and look closely
you'll see a field of dreams
the ground in which america's future
will be built
that's for intel the american company
that helped build silicon valley
is going to build a 20 billion dollar
semiconductor mega site
up to eight state-of-the-art factories
in one place
10
000 new jobs
in those factories the average job of
about 135 dollars 135 thousand dollars a
year
some most sophisticated manufacturing in
the world
to make
computer ships the size of a fingertip
the power of the world in everyday lives
from smartphones technology the the
internet technology has yet to be
invented
but that's just the beginning
intel ceo pat gelsinger who's here
tonight i know where pat is pat there
you go pat stand up
pat came to see me and he told me
they're ready to increase their
investment from 20 billion
to 100 billion
that would be the biggest investment in
manufacturing in american history
and all they're waiting for is for you
to pass this bill
so let's not wait any longer
send it to my desk i'll sign it
and we'll really take off in a big way
and folks
intel is not alone
there's something happening in america
just look around and you'll see an
amazing story
the rebirth of pride that comes from
stamping products made in america the
revitalization of american manufacturing
companies are choosing to build new
factories here
when just a few years ago they would
have gone overseas
that's what's happening
ford is investing 11 billion dollars in
electric vehicles creating 11 000 jobs
across the country
gm is making the largest investment in
his history
seven billion dollars to build electric
vehicles creating 4 000 jobs in michigan
all told
369 000 new manufacturing jobs were
created in america last year alone
folks
powered by people i've met like jojo
burgess
from generations of union steel workers
in pittsburgh who's here us tonight
where are you jojo
there you go thanks buddy
as ohio
as ohio senator sherrod brown says
sherrod brown says it's time to bury the
label rust bell
it's time
to see
the
the what used to be called the rust belt
become this the the home of a
significant resurgence of manufacturing
and with all the bright spots in our
economy
record job growth higher wages too many
families are struggling to keep up with
their bills
inflation
is robbing them of gains they thought
otherwise they would be able to feel
i get it
that's why my top priority is getting
prices under control look
our economy roared back faster than
almost anyone predicted but pandemic
meant that businesses
had a hard time hiring enough people
because of the pandemic
to keep up production in their factories
she didn't have people making those
beams that went in the buildings because
they were out the factory was closed
the panic also disrupted the global
supply chain factories close
when that happens it takes longer to
make goods and get them to the
warehouses to the stores and go prices
go up
look at cars last year
one third of all the inflation was
because of automobile sales there
weren't enough semiconductors to make
all the cars that people wanted to buy
and guess what
prices of automobiles went way up
especially used vehicles as well but
and so we have a choice
one way to fight inflation is to drive
down wages and make americans poor
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your costs not your wages
folks
that means make more cars than
semiconductors in america
more infrastructure and innovation in
america
more goods moving faster and cheaper in
america
more jobs where you can earn a good
living in america
instead of relying on foreign supply
chains let's make it in america
look
economist
[Applause]
economist
all this increasing the productive
capacity of our company our economy
i call it building a better america
my plan
to fight inflation
will lower your cost and lower the
deficit
17 nobel laureates in economics said my
plan will ease long-term inflationary
pressures
top business leaders
and i believe most americans support the
plan and here's the plan
first
cut the cost of prescription drugs
we pay more
for the same drug
produced by the same company
in america than any other country in the
world
just look at insulin
one in ten americans has diabetes
in virginia i met a 13 year old boy that
handsome young man standing up there
joshua davis
he and his dad both have type 1 diabetes
which means they need insulin every
single day
insulin cost about 10 dollars a vial to
make
that's what it costs
the pharmaceutical company
but drug companies charge families like
joshua and his dad up to 30 times that
amount
i spoke with joshua's mom
imagine what it's like to look at your
child
who needs insulin to stay healthy
and have no idea how in god's name
you're going to be able to pay for it
what it does to your family but what it
does to your dignity
your ability to look your child in the
eye
to be the parent you expect yourself to
be
i really mean to think about that that's
what i think about
you know
yesterday joshua's here tonight but
yesterday was his birthday happy
birthday buddy by the way
for joshua
and 200 000 other young people with type
1 diabetes
let's cap the cost of insulin 35 a month
so everyone can afford it
and drug companies will do very very
well their proper margin
while we're at it i know we have great
disagreements on this floor with this
let's let medicare negotiate the price
of prescription drugs
they already
[Music]
set the price for va drugs
look the american rescue plan is helping
millions of families with affordable
care act plans to save them 2 400 a year
on their health premiums let's close the
coverage gap and make these savings
permanent
and second
let's cut energy costs for families
an average of 500 a year by combating
climate change let's provide an
investment tax credits to weatherize
your home
and your business
to be energy efficient and get a tax
credit for it
double americans clean energy production
in solar wind and so much more lower the
price of electric vehicles saving
another eighty dollars a month that
you're not going to have to pay at the
pump
folks
third
the third thing we can do to change the
standard of living for hardworking folks
is cut the cost of child care
cut the cost of childhood
oops
if you live in a major city in america
you pay up to 14 000 a year for child
care per child
i was a single dad for five years
raising two kids i had a lot of help
though
i had a mom a dad a brother and a sister
that really helped
but middle class and working folks
shouldn't have to pay more than seven
percent of their income to care for the
young children
my plan
my plan would cut the cost
of child care in half for most families
and help parents including millions of
women who left the workforce during the
pandemic because they couldn't afford
child care
to be able to get back to work
generating economic growth
but my plan doesn't stop there it also
includes home and long-term care more
affordable housing
pre-k for three and four-year-olds
all these will lower costs for families
and under my plan nobody let me say this
again nobody earning less than 400 000 a
year will pay an additional penny in new
taxes not a single penny
i may be wrong
but my guess is if we took a secret
ballot in this floor
that we'd all agree that the president
tax system ain't fair
we have to fix it
i'm not looking to punish anybody
but let's make corporations and wealthy
americans start paying their fair share
look
last year
last year
[Applause]
like chris coons and tom carper
and my distinguished congresswoman
we come from the land of corporate
america there are more corporations
incorporated in america than every other
state in america combined
and i still won 36 years in a row
the point is
even they understand they should pay
just a fair share last year 55 of the
fortune 500 companies
earned 40 billion dollars in profit and
paid zero in federal taxes
now look it's not fair
that's why i proposed a 15 minimum tax
rate for corporations
we've got
and that's why
in the g7 other meetings overseas we're
able to put together i was able to be
somewhat helpful 130 countries degree on
a global minimum tax rate
so companies can't get out of paying
their taxes at home by shipping jobs in
factories overseas
it'll raise billions of dollars that's
why i propose closing loopholes for the
very wealthy who don't pay
who pay a lower tax rate than a teacher
and a firefighter
so that's my plan but we have to go more
detail later
i'm going to grow we will grow the
economy
lower the cost of families
so what are we waiting for let's get
this done we all know we've got to make
changes
folks
and while you're at it
confirm my nominees for the federal
reserve
which plays a critical role
in fighting inflation
my plan will not only lower cost and
give families a fair shot
it will lower the deficit
the previous administration not only
ballooned the deficit with those tax
cuts for the very wealthy incorporations
it
undermined the watchdogs
the job of those who keep pandemic
relief funds being wasted remember we
had those debates
about whether or not those watchdogs
should be able to see every day how much
money was being spent where was it going
to the right place
and in my administration
the watchdogs are back
and we're going to go after the
criminals who stole billions of relief
money meant for small business and
millions of americans tonight i'm
announcing that the justice department
will soon name a chief prosecutor for
pandemic fraud
[Applause]
[Music]
i think we all agree thank you
by the end of this year the depths will
be down to less than half of what it was
before i took office
the only president ever to cut the
deficit by more than one trillion
dollars in a single year
lowering your cost also meant demanding
more competition
i'm a capitalist but capitalism without
competition is not
capitalism
capitalism without competition is
exploitation
it drives up profits
[Applause]
and corporations have to compete
their profits go up and your prices go
up when they don't have to compete small
businesses and family farmers and
ranchers i need not tell some of my
republican friends from those states
guess what
you got four basic meat packing
facilities
that's it
you play with them you don't get to play
at all and you pay a hell of a lot more
a hell of a lot more because only four
see what's happening with ocean carriers
and moving goods in and out of america
during the pandemic
about half a dozen or less foreign owned
companies raised prices by as much as 1
000
and made record profits
tonight
i'm announcing a crackdown on those
companies over charging american
businesses and consumers
folks
and as wall street firms take over more
nursing homes
in those homes has gone down
and costs have gone up
that ends on my watch
medicare is going to set higher
standards for nursing homes and make
sure your loved ones get the care they
deserve and that they inspect and they
will look that closely
we're also going to cut costs to keep
the economy going strong and giving
workers a fair shot
provide more training and
apprenticeships higher than based on
skills not just their degrees
let's pass the paycheck fairness act and
paid me
raise the minimum wage to 15 an hour
and extend the child tax credit so no
one has to raise the family in poverty
let's increase pell grants increase our
historic support for hbcus
and invest
in what jill our first lady who teaches
full-time calls america's best kept
secret community colleges
let's pass the pro act
when the majority of workers want a
former union they shouldn't be able to
be stopped
when we invest in our workers and we
build an economy from the bottom up in
the middle out together we can do
something we haven't done in a long time
build a better america
for more than two years covet has
impacted every decision in our lives
and the life of this nation
and i know you're tired frustrated and
exhausted
that doesn't even count
close to a million people who sit at a
dining room table or a kitchen table
look at an empty chair
because they lost somebody
but i also know this
because of the progress we've made
because of your resilience
and the tools that we have been provided
by this congress
tonight i can say we're moving forward
safely
back to no no more normal routines
we've reached a new moment in the fight
against covet 19
where severe cases are down no level not
seen since july of last year
just a few days ago the center for
disease control and prevention
issued a new mass guidelines
under the new guidelines most americans
and most of the country
can now go mask free
and based on projections
based on projection
more of the country will reach a point
across that point across the next couple
of weeks
thanks to the progress we've made in the
past year covet 19 no longer need
control our lives
i know some are talking about living
with covet 19. but tonight i say
that we never will just accept living
with cover 19
we'll continue to combat the virus as we
do other diseases
and because this virus mutates and
spreads we have to stay on guard
and here are four common sense steps as
we move forward safely in my view
first
stay protected with vaccines and
treatments
we know how incredibly effective
vaccines are
if you're vaccinated and boosted
you have the highest degree of
protection
we'll never give up on vaccinating more
americans
now i know parents with kids under 5 are
eager to see their vaccines authorized
for their children
scientists are working hard to get that
done we'll be ready with plenty of
vaccines if and when they do
we're all ready
we are also ready with antiviral
treatments
if you get covered 19 the pfizer pill
reduces your chances of ending up in the
hospital by 90 percent
i've ordered more pills than anyone in
the world has
pfizer is working overtime to get us a
million pills this month
and more than double that next month and
now we're launching the test to treat
initiative
so people can get tested at a pharmacy
and if they prove positive receive the
antiviral pills on the spot at no cost
folks
if you're in
if you're immunocompromised or have some
other vulnerability
we have treatments
and free high quality mass
we're leaving no one behind or ignoring
anyone's needs as we move forward
on testing
we've made hundreds of millions of tests
available and you can order them for
free to your doorstep and we've already
ordered free tests if you're already
ordered free test tonight
i'm announcing you can order another
group of tests
go to coventest.gov starting next week
and you can get more tests
second
we must prepare for new variants
over the past we've gotten much better
at detecting new variants
if necessary we'll be able to develop
new vaccines within 100 days instead of
maybe months or years and if congress
presides the funds we need we'll have
new stockpiles of tests mass pills ready
if needed
i can't promise a new variant won't come
but i can't i can't promise you we'll do
everything within our power to be ready
if it does
third
we can end the shutdown of schools and
businesses
we have the tools we need
it's time for america to get back to
work and fill our great downtowns again
with people people working from home can
feel safe and begin to return to their
offices
we're doing that here in the federal
government
the vast majority of federal workers
will once again work in person our
schools are open let's keep it that way
our kids need to be in school
the 75 percent of the 75 of adult
americans fully vaccinated
and hospitalizations down by 77 percent
most americans can remove their masks
and stay in the classroom and move
forward safely
we achieved this because we provided
free vaccines treatments tests and masks
of course continuing this costs money
so i'll not surprise you i'll be back to
see you all
and we i'm going to soon send a request
to congress
the vast majority of americans have used
these tools and they want again
we may need them again so i expect
congress and i hope you'll pass that
quickly
fourth
we'll continue vaccinating the world
we've sent 475 million vaccine doses to
112 countries more than any nation on
earth
we won't stop
because you can't build a wall high
enough to keep out
a
a a vaccine the vaccine can stop
the spread
of these diseases
you know we've lost so much in covenant
19
time with one another
the worst of all much loss of life
let's use this moment to reset
so stop looking at covet as a partisan
dividing line
see it for what it is
a god-awful disease
let's stop sending each seeing each
other as enemies
start seeing each other for who we are
fellow americans
look
[Applause]
we
we can't change how divided we've been
there's a long time in coming
but we can change how to move forward
on covet 19 and other issues that we
must face together
i recently visited new york city police
department days after the funerals
officer
wilbur mora and his partner officer
jason rivera
they were responding to a 911 call when
the man shot and killed him with a
stolen gun
officer moore was 27 years old officer
vera was 22 years old
both dominican americans who grew up in
the same streets
that they later chose the parole to uh
patrol as police officers
i spoke with their families
and i told them that we are forever in
debt for their sacrifices
and will carry on their mission to
restore the trust and safety in every
community deserves
like some of you have been around for a
while
i've worked with you on these issues for
a long time
i know what works
investigating crime prevention and
community policing
cops who walk the beat who know the
neighborhood
and who can restore trust and safety
let's not abandon our streets
or choose between safety and equal
justice
let's come together and protect our
communities restore trust and hold law
enforcement accountable
that's why the justice department has
required body cameras
banned choke calls and restricted no
knox warrants for its officers
that's why the american rescue plan
that you all provided 350 billion
dollars
that cities states and counties can use
to hire more police invest in more
proven
strategies proven strands like
proven strategies like community
violence interruption trusted messengers
breaking the cycle of violence and
trauma
giving young people some hope
we should all agree the answer is not to
defund the police
it's to fund the police
fund them
fund them
fund them with resources and training
resources and training they need to
protect our communities
[Applause]
i asked democrats and republicans alike
to pass my budget and keep our
neighborhoods safe
and we'll do everything in my power to
crack down on gun trafficking of ghost
guns that you can buy online
assemble at home
no serial numbers can't be traced
i asked congress to pass proven measures
to reduce gun violence
pass universal background checks why
should anyone on the terrorist list be
able to purchase a weapon why
why
folks
ban assault weapons with high capacity
magazines hold up a hundred rounds
you think the deer are wearing kevlar
vests
look repeal the liability shield that
makes gun manufacturers the only
industry in america that can't be sued
the only one
imagine had we done that with the
tobacco manufacturers
these laws don't infringe on the second
amendment
they save lives
the most fundamental right in america is
the right to vote and have it counted
and look
it's under assault
in state after state new laws have been
passed
it's not only suppressed about we've
been there before but to subvert the
entire election
we can't let this happen
tonight i call on the senate to pass
pass the freedom to vote act pass the
john lewis act voting rights act
and while you're at it
pass the disclose act so americans know
who's funding our election
look
tonight
i'd like to honor someone who dedicated
his life to serve this country
justice breyer
an army veteran
constitutional scholar
retiring justice of the united states
supreme court
justice breyer thank you for your
service
thank you thank you thank you
you mean it
give us can't live
we all know
no matter what your ideology we all know
one of the most serious constitutional
responsibility a president has
is nominating someone to serve
on the united states supreme court
as i did four days ago
i've nominated a circuit court of
appeals
katangi brown jackson
one of our nation's top legal minds
will continue and just bribe justice
briar's
legacy of
excellence former top litigator in
private practice
a former federal public defender
from a family of public school educators
and police officers
she's a consensus builder
since she's been nominated she's
received a broad range of support
including the fraternal order of police
and former judges supported by democrats
and republicans
folks
if we are to advance liberty and justice
we need to secure our border and fix the
immigration system
[Applause]
as you might guess i think we can do
both
at our border
we've installed new technology like
cutting-edge scanners to better detect
drug smuggling we've set up joint
patrols of mexico and guatemala to catch
more human traffickers
we're putting in place dedicated
immigration judges a significant larger
number so families fleeing persecution
and violence can have their curses cases
heard faster and those who don't
legitimately hear can be sent back
we're screening we're securing
commitments and supporting partners in
south and central america to host more
refugees and secure their own borders we
can do all this while keeping lit the
torch of liberty that has led the
generation of immigrants to this land
my forebears and many of yours
provide a pathway to citizens for
dreamers
those with temporary status farm workers
essential workers
revise our laws
so businesses have workers they need
and families don't wait decades reunite
it's not only the right thing to do it's
economically smart thing to do
that's why the immigration reform is
supported by everyone from labor unions
to religious leaders to the u.s chamber
of commerce
let's get it done once and for all
folks
advancing liberty and justice also
requires
protecting the rights of women
a constitutional right affirmed by roe v
wade standing president for half a
century is under attack as never before
if you want to go forward not backwards
we must protect access to health care
preserve a woman's right to choose and
continue to advance maternal health care
for all americans
and folks
for our lgbtq plus americans
let's finally get the bipartisan
equality act to my desk
the onslaught of state laws targeting
transgender americans and their families
it's simply wrong
i've said last year especially to our
younger transgender americans i'll
always have your back as your president
so you can be yourself and reach your
god-given potential
folks
as i've
just
it all often appears we do not agree
and that
we we do agree on a lot more things than
we acknowledge
i signed 80 bipartisan bills in the law
last year
from preventing government shutdowns
protecting asian americans from still
too common hate crimes to reforming
military justice
and will soon be strengthening the
violence against women act that i first
wrote three decades ago
it's important
it's important for us to show
to show the nation
we can come together and do big things
tonight i'm offering a unity agenda for
the nation
four big things we can do together in my
view
first
beat the opioid
epidemic
there's so much
we can do
increased funding for prevention
treatment
harm reduction and recovery get rid of
outdated rules and stop doctors and
that stop doctors prescribing
treatments
stop the flow of illicit drugs by
working with state and local law
enforcement to go after the traffickers
and if you're suffering from addiction
you know you should know you're not
alone
i believe in recovery and i celebrate
the 23 million
23 million americans in recovery
second
let's take on mental health
especially among our children whose
lives and education have been
turned upside down
american rescue plan gave schools money
to hire teachers and help students make
up for lost learning
i urge every parent to make sure your
school your school does just that they
have the money
we can all play a part
sign up to be a tutor or a mentor
children were also struggling before the
pandemic bullying violence trauma
and the harms of social media
as francis
haugen
who is here tonight with us has shown we
must hold social media platforms
accountable for the national experiment
they're conducting on our children for
profit
folks
thank you
thank you for the courage you showed
it's time to strengthen privacy
protections
ban targeted advertising to children
demand tech companies stop collecting
personal data on our children
and let's get all americans the mental
health services they need
more people can turn for help
and full parity between physical and
mental health care if we treat it that
way in our insurance
look
the third piece of that agenda
is support our veterans
veterans are the backbone and the spine
of this country
they're the best of us
i've always believed
that we have a sacred obligation to
cryptos we send to war
and care for those in their family when
they come home
my administration providing assistance
in job training housing and now helping
lower income veterans get va care debt
free
and our troops in iraq have faced in
afghanistan face many dangers
one being stationed at bases breathing
in toxic smoke from burn pits
many of you have been there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
these burn pits that incinerate waste
the waste of war
medical
and hazards material jet fuel and so
much more
and they come home
many of the world's fittest and best
trained warriors in the world
never the same
headaches numbness dizziness
a cancer that would put them in a
flag-draped coffin
i know
one of those
one of those soldiers was my son major
beaubiden
i don't know for sure if the burn pit
that he lived near that his hooch was
near
in iraq and earlier than that in kosovo
is the cause of his brain cancer the
disease of so many other troops
but i am committed
to find out everything we can
committed
to military families like danielle
robinson from ohio
the widow of sergeant first class heath
robinson
he was born a soldier
army national guard
combat medic in kosovo in iraq
stationed near baghdad just yards from
burn pitch the size of football fields
danielle is here with us
tonight they love going to ohio state
football games
[Applause]
he loved building legos with their
daughter
cancer from prolonged exposure to burnt
pits
ravaged peace lungs and body
danielle says heath was a fighter to the
very end
he didn't know how to stop fighting
and neither did she
through her pain she found purpose
to demand that we do better
tonight danielle we are going to do
better
va
the va is firing new ways of linking
toxic disclosure to disease
already helping more
veterans get benefits and tonight
i'm announcing we're expanding
eligibility to veterans suffering from
nine respiratory cancers
i'm also calling on congress to pass a
law to make sure veterans devastated by
toxic exposure in iraq and afghanistan
finally get the benefits and the
comprehensive health care
and fourth and last
let's end cancer as we know it
this is personal
this is personal meaning to jill and the
kamala and so many of you
so many of you have lost someone you
love
husband wife son daughter mom dad
cancer is the number two cause of death
in america second only to heart disease
last month
i announced the plan to supercharge the
cancer moonshot that president obama
asked me to lead six years ago
our goal is to cut cancer death rates by
at least 50 percent over the next 25
years i think we can do better than that
turn cancers
from death sentences into treatable
diseases
more support for patients and their
families
to get there i call on congress to fund
what i call arpa h advanced
advanced research
projects agency for health
pattern after darpa in the defense
department
projects that led in darpa to the
internet gps and so much more to make
our
forces more safer and be able to wage
war more with more clarity
arpa will have a singular purpose
to drive breakthroughs in cancer
alzheimer's and diabetes
and more
a unity agenda for the nation
we can do these things it's within our
power and i don't see a partisan edge to
any one of those four things
my fellow
americans tonight
we've gathered in this sacred space
a citadel of democracy
in this capital
generation after generation americans
have debated great questions
amid great strife
and have done great things
we fought for freedom
expanded liberty
debated totalitarianism and terror
we built the strongest
freest and most prosperous nation the
world has ever known
now is the hour
our moment of responsibility
our test of resolve and conscience
of history itself
it is in this moment
that our character this generation is
formed
our purpose is found
our future is forged
well i know this nation
we'll meet the test
protect freedom and liberty
expand fairness and opportunity
and we will save democracy
as hard as those times have been i'm
more optimistic about america today than
i've been my whole life because i see
the future that's within our grasp
because i know there's simply nothing
beyond our camas our capacity
we're the only nation on earth that has
always turned every crisis we faced into
an opportunity
the only nation that can be defined by a
single word possibilities
so on this night
on our 245th year as a nation
i've come to report on the state of the
nation the state of the union and my
report is this the state of the union is
strong because you the american people
are strong
we are stronger today
we are stronger today than we were a
year ago
and we'll be stronger a year from now
than we are today
this is our moment
to meet and overcome the challenges of
our time and we will as one people one
america the united states of america
god bless you all
and may god protect our troops
thank you
go get him
[Applause]
thank
you to see you guys
[Music]
thank you thank you
well done mr president
great clothes thank you president thanks
for coming to colorado
[Music]
yes
nice
besides we got the best damn generals in
the world
all
all
right
okay
thank you
oh
[Music]
man you know it's true
is
listen man i'm trying to take care of
myself
[Music]
it's great
thank you
okay
oh
thank you
oh
inappropriate in every way i kept
stepping up and saying don't joke
i was jumping up the whole time
i keep trying
this lady too
thank you so much i greatly appreciate
it as a matter of fact
i'm going to get a selfie with you
give him the camera he'll do this okay
let's do it
thank god my mother didn't hear that
vice president
so i'll see you on thursday
oh
an incredible family her sister used to
run my fellow operations
thank you
[Laughter]
oh
is
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
okay
together
[Music]
yes
crazy
[Music]
oh
thank you
and uh
[Laughter]
thank you so much
all right
on you guys you better be careful
very good old days
okay
excuse me thank you
how are you
how are you
well thanks for smiling no oh i was
inspired tonight
[Music]
that would be the reason